thank you
and welcome to Hannity and tonight we
are in beautiful Palm Beach Florida
broadcasting from Mar-A-Lago where in
just a moment the 45th president of the
United States Donald J Trump he will
join us for his very first sit-down
interview since roughly 30 federal
agents guns drawn stormed through the
doors right here in the president's own
home now in what was obviously an
unprecedented rate historically but we
begin with a few serious questions for
everybody watching tonight do we have an
America today equal justice under the
law we have equal application of our
laws in this country to our local state
and federal officials do they
investigate crimes or prosecute people
if America's justice system is ever
weaponized and politicized Beyond repair
this country that we all love we are in
big trouble I'll take a look at New York
attorney general Leticia James now today
she filed a lawsuit against Donald Trump
and three of his children and other
entities claiming that they inflated the
value of the Trump organization it is
nothing short but a very obvious
political stunt it is not a criminal
case it is a civil case but after three
years of non-stop obsessive
investigations into every aspect of the
president's life well Leticia James she
had to do something because during her
race for attorney general in the state
of New York she seemed totally
completely uninterested with
investigating crimes or keeping New York
safe from violent offenders it's less
safe than it's ever been instead her
main campaign pledge was to go after one
man Donald Trump and Donald Trump's
family and Donald Trump's organization
well today in front of the entire nation
she fulfilled her campaign promise take
a look
I will never be afraid to challenge this
illegitimate president when our
fundamental rights are at stake I
believe that the president of these
United States can be indicted for
criminal offenses will you sue him for
us
that man in the White House
[Music]
a day
without threatening our fundamental
rights yes we need to focus on Donald
Trump and his abuses we need to follow
his money
we need to find out where he's laundered
money we need to find out whether or not
he's engaged in conspiracy
now is it any Wonder these numbers came
out today the state of New York set a
brand new record for the month of August
5
838 residents in the state of New York
have now switched in 30 days 31 days
their driver's licenses from New York to
Florida that's in one month now the
Attorney General isn't even trying to
hide her efforts to weaponize Justice in
New York state her conduct is deeply
unethical at best but she's not alone
now from the Trump haters on Capitol
Hill high-ranking deep State bureaucrats
and the doj the FBI now we have
witnessed going on many years the 45th
president has been the subject of what
is non-stop never-ending legal scrutiny
focused not on a specific crime but on
the man himself now this is an intense
legal scrutiny that no Democrat has ever
faced no other president has ever faced
for example for the first time in
history an American president's home was
raided by the FBI Biden his main
opponent in 2020 maybe 2024 while his
doj is accusing former president Trump
of holding on to 103 classified
documents after his presidency now they
have 11 000 that were not controversial
in any way and by the way a president
can declassify any of these documents
unlike for example Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton she cannot we'll get to
that in a minute still she stored 110
classified documents on unsecured
private servers Hillary Clinton was
never forced to endure a federal raid
she was never charged with any crime now
here is James Comey in his own words
outlying all the classified information
that he and his FBI at the time that
they found and then stating no
reasonable prosecutor would ever bring a
case against Clinton take a look
110 emails in 52 email chains have been
determined by the owning agency to
contain classified information at the
time they were sent or received eight of
those chains contained information that
was Top Secret at the time they were
sent
36 of those chains contained secret
information at the time
and eight contained confidential
information at the time although we did
not find clear evidence that secretary
Clinton or her colleagues intended to
violate laws governing the handling of
classified information there is evidence
that they were extremely careless in
their handling of very sensitive highly
classified information although there is
evidence of potential violations of the
statutes regarding the handling of
classified information
our judgment is that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring such a case
now keep in mind with what you just
heard 33 000 emails on servers and hard
drives remember nobody had ever heard of
something called bleachbit well she
washed the servers those hard drives
clean with bleach bit now the country
knows what it is also communication
devices they were destroyed with hammers
SIM cards removed from phones and
blackberries one set of rules for Trump
another for Hillary Clinton now we see
the same thing by the way with the
bidens Joe Biden and his family as
president Trump was impeached over a
routine phone call with Ukraine saying I
hope you're not going to be like your
predecessors and abuse the money of my
tax paying fellow Americans well they
accused president Trump at the time of a
quid pro quo we went through an
impeachment over that apparently though
on the other hand it was perfectly fine
Joe Biden bragging on tape that he
literally leveraged one billion of your
taxpayer dollars to get a prosecutor in
Ukraine fired we find out why for
investigating his son who's making
millions with no experience is this
equal justice take a look we're not
going to give you the billion dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars I said you're
not getting a billion I'm going to be
leaving here and I think it was what six
hours I look I said leave it in six
hours if the prosecutor is not fired
you're not getting the money oh son
got fired
now the prosecutor Joe wanted well is
gone after six hours the son of a bee is
gone when the investigation for his son
Hunter for public corruption for years
has been going on zero experienced
hunter that prosecutor was investigating
he went on GMA no experience in oil or
gas or energy or Ukraine and he was
traveling the world with his father
selling access to the office and then
Vice President Biden making millions of
dollars from communist China 150 billion
dollar deal there again no experience a
Russian oligarch the former first lady
of Moscow uh three and a half million
dollars Kazakhstan and every other
corrupt country they could on the face
of the Earth and then by the way he then
allegedly funneled that money back to
the United States there are issues
involving taxes there uh Tony bobolinski
told the country that he had the he was
the big guy he sat in the meetings they
were going to give him his percentage
meaning Joe by Biden and meanwhile
Hunter was on video with the laptop that
everybody said three weeks before the
2020 election was Russian disinformation
it wasn't but there he is smoking crack
soliciting foreign prostitutes and
according uh and the recording all of it
on the laptop that the FBI has now had
for years oh and he also lied on a gun
application lost track of that gun it
ended up in a dumpster near an
elementary school but Hunter's home his
home was never raided Joe's home it's
never been raided we now have all the
evidence that one could ever want the
Joe Biden knew of a knowingly profited
from his son Hunter's Farm business
dealings he lied to the country when he
said I've never one time talked to my
son about his foreign business dealings
now the media mob I know you're watching
tonight welcome aboard they won't even
ask him about why he lied all the
evidence exist he did meet many of
Hunter Biden's business partners foreign
business partners and according to
whistleblowers we're expecting a lot of
them in the coming weeks and months
high-ranking Federal officials attempted
to either slow walk or in fact block
investigations into these apparent
crimes so tonight
I asked the media mob I know you're
watching I asked the Attorney General
mayor Garland I know you're watching I
asked FBI director Ray I'm sure you're
all watching is this really the America
you want is this the justice system that
the American people deserve where
political Justice and vengeance is doled
out by those in power While others are
protected and shielded from prosecution
because the Pendulum by the way I will
remind you it will swing and right now
we are headed down a very dark path and
I want to be very clear I'm very clear
I'm a conservative and I would never
want in the United States of America I
believe the greatest country God gave
man any Democrat any socialist to be
treated unfairly not to have equal
justice or application of our laws that
would be unconstitutional hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will will not get it
anywhere else